Oh my god.
Nothing.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
We are good.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Look at the box.
Little box.
Yeah, I don't know how well these are
charged.
>> Well, good evening. Good evening.
>> As we're gathering in here,
>> we're so glad that you came this
evening.
My name is Catna. My pronouns are she
and her.
Whether this is your first visit or this
is your first time in a long time or
we we're glad that you're here and that
you chose to be here this evening. With
that being said, some of us have anxiety
about being in a church setting.
We have an accessibility bucket over on
that table that has some coloring sheets
and some little bubble popping
fidget thingies that I love
and some uh little earplugs.
Feel free to pick those up and you can
just drop them off on your way out.
I have a couple of announcements.
Our next Sunday Unbound
is going to be Sunday, March 1st in the
Family Life Center, which is the
connect.
>> Oh, so no, no, that's fine, Megan.
>> No, you're fine. But yes, it Can I just
say that it will be in the family life
center and we're going to do a potluck?
Oh, we're going to do a potluck.
>> We don't know the date, but hey, there
will be food. That's the important
thing. Okay, the game night that we had
to reschedu because of the snow ice
thing that took place uh will be this
Friday, February the 20 20th. Uh since
it's now spring,
um please come bring your favorite game,
your favorite dessert, and there will be
a pasta bar set up. So please come at
6:00 till 8:30, and it will be in the
family life center.
The Ash Wednesday, Ash is a season of
fasting and prayer known as Lent.
And there is an Ash Wednesday service
that will be held here at the Saxi
United Methodist Church and they have
invited us to join them if we would like
to. That will be this when this Tuesday.
Um, isn't that Yeah. February the 18th.
Tuesday. Yes. Wednesday. Wednesday.
Sorry.
um this Wednesday, February the 18th,
and all are invited to attend. And is
that at 7? Pastor Brett, do you know if
it's a seven or seven? That's a good
Methodist time. 7 o'clock.
Okay.
These candles
are a symbol of the presence of Christ
among us.
Fully divine
and fully human.
Now we can turn to the time of worship.
We exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter king the kingdom of
silence,
stillness and grace.
Now we enter sacred space.
A space for prayer, worship and
adoration.
A space to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thank you, Cat. If you guys would stand
with us, we're going to get started
tonight with uh Gary's going to lead us
in um Stand in Your Love. So, you guys
join in if you know the song and if not,
you're still invited to bring your whole
self into this space. um we don't want
there to be a division between the stage
and the seats out there, but instead
this is an allplay. This is a communal
event in which we get the honor and uh
the privilege of being able to sing out
together some truths that we believe um
and that we want to sink ourselves into.
So you guys be a part of that to
whatever extent you're able.
Darkness tries to roll over my bones.
When sorrow comes to steal the joy I
own.
When brokenness and pain is all I know.
Oh, I won't be shen.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. My fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
love. My fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand in your love.
Shame no longer has a place to hide.
And I am not a captive to the lies.
>> I'm not afraid to leave my past behind.
>> Oh, I won't be shen.
My fear doesn't stand a chance. When I
stand in your love, my fear, it doesn't
stand a chance. When I stand in your
love, my fear, it doesn't stand a
chance. When I stand in your love,
>> there's power that can break off every
chain.
There's power that can empty out a
grave.
>> There's resurrection power that can
save. There's power in your name.
There's power in your name.
>> There's power that can break off every
chain.
>> There's power that can empty out a
grave.
There's resurrection power that can
save. There's power in your name.
There's power in your name.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. And my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
love. And my fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand in your love.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. My fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
love. My fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand in your love.
>> Standing in your love.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to go to their classrooms with
their teachers and they'll meet you
right over here by the double doors.
Thank you guys for singing and dancing
with us.
Love the joy.
And thank you to our kids ministry team
who are going to be hanging out and
loving on these kiddos tonight. um for
Charles and Harper and I don't know who
all is back there.
>> Valerie and Risa, you guys.
>> Such a great team. Very grateful for
them.
>> Yeah.
>> Um we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people. If this is your
first time to be with us tonight, this
is a tradition that's been passed down
through Christian history that we like
to partake in. Um, it's just an
opportunity for us to be honest about
the things that we carry into this space
and hold them up before God together as
a community, believing that he is with
us in our suffering and our pain with
with others that we are caring for. So,
um, I'll read the parts in black and we
can all say the parts in red together up
on the screens. And then we'll pause for
a minute in the middle of the prayer for
you to speak out loud if you would like
to, a name or a situation that you're
carrying um on your heart tonight and
then we'll close out the prayer together
at the end.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us, and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you. Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you
now.
For the names and the moments that we
have spend. spoken aloud. And for those
that we have kept in our hearts, we pray
to you that they may have life and
light, healing and hope, peace and a
deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
The other day I was, you know, scrolling
as we do sometimes and I came across
this poet. His name is Jonathan Germa.
And I'm not going to read the whole
poem, but I just wanted to read an
excerpt from it. Um, if you're
interested later, let me know and I will
shoot it to you. Um, because it really
was like one of those things that
challenged me. But he was just kind of
talking about how our faith can remain
this idea in our head or this thing that
we say or it can be something that's
lived. Um, some of it goes like this.
When I asked if you believed in God,
what I meant was, "Where does your mind
run when it races?" Who carries the
weight of your unspoken questions or
desires? I wasn't asking if you know any
of the Bible. I was asking if the Bible
knows you. The one on your nightstand,
does it recognize the texture of your
skin? Does it have pages that have bent
and stretched under your tears? I wasn't
asking if you think abortion is wrong or
if caring for the poor is important or
if you think that prayer works. I was
asking if your pockets know the emptying
that comes with generosity. If your face
knows tears that were shed on someone
else's behalf, the ones that get pulled
down by gravity. With all due respect, I
know we're used to saying what we
believe, but what moves us?
Do you know joy or peace? Does she ever
make you danced? Has she ever kissed
your forehead?
Sometimes I wonder if actors are better
off. At least they know the difference
between reading lines and getting into
character. They know that the script
doesn't come alive when your mind knows
what to say, but when your body wears
the story. When I asked if you believe
in God, what I meant was, "What God do
you know? And how much of you knows him?
We have suffered all kinds of grief.
Tasted the bitter cup of deed
by so many fires.
Burning the heat of what our hopes.
Find us here singing in a foolish.
Our faith more preious than gold.
Our faith more preious gold.
We don't see you. We love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
We've got a reason to trust you,
Jesus, in everything.
There is a secret we can only know.
Walking through places we don't want to
know.
>> Cuz in the dark we learn the song of
hope. Our faith more precious than gold.
Our faith more precious than gold.
And
>> though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
We've got reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
Tears on the altar
from all we lost.
Following you no matter what it cost.
Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who love you, Lord.
>> Sing tears, tears on the altar
from all we lost,
following you, no matter what it cost.
Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who love you, Lord.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
Cuz we've got a reason to trust you,
Jesus, in everything. Let's sing that
again.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
And we don't feel you, we still see.
We've got a reason to trust you,
Jesus, in everything.
Jesus.
Jesus in everything.
Sing tears. Tears on the altar from all
we lost.
Following you no matter what it cost.
Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who love you, Lord. This is the
sound of those who love you, Lord.
Let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run, the fountain that I drink
from. Oh, is my song.
Let the king of my heart be the shadow
where I hide, the ransom for my life.
Oh, he is my song. Sing. You are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good. Good. You're good.
you are good. You're good.
Oh,
let the king of my heart be the wind
inside my s, the anchor in the waves. So
is my song.
Let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins, the echo of my days.
>> Let's sing that one more time. Let the
king of my heart be the wind inside my
sails, the anchor in the waves. Oh, he
is my soul.
Let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins,
the echo of my days. Oh, he is my song.
You are good. You're good.
Oh,
you are good. You're good.
you're never going to let never going to
let me down.
You're never going to let never going to
let me down. down.
let me down.
You're never going to never going to let
me down.
You're never going to live You're never
going to let me down.
You're never going to live. You're never
going to lift me down.
Never going to let You're never going to
let me down. You are good. You're good.
Oh,
you are good. You're good.
you're never going to let never going to
let me down.
>> You're good. You're never going to let
never going to let me down.
never going to let me down. You are
good. You're good.
You are good.
You're good.
God, thank you that we can trust you,
that we can depend on who you are.
God, that you will be a firm foundation
when everything else is sinking sand.
God, tonight I'm reminded of the cost of
our faith.
But it's not always easy.
It's not a prosperity gospel. It doesn't
mean everything's going to be bigger and
grander.
Sometimes it means things are harder
because we have to hold a line.
Sometimes it means we sacrifice on
behalf of someone else.
Sometimes we give up things so that
others can have what they need. And
that's what real gospel looks like.
That's what the love of Jesus was for
us. One that laid down its life.
One that saw the broken and the needy
and the undeserved. And he came and he
ate with them. He loved them.
God, would we be that?
God, would our faith change us? Would it
be real in our lives? Not just words
that we say when we come together on
Sundays,
but something that's lived, that has a
home in our body, not just our brains.
Change us, Jesus. Change me.
Make us more like you.
We need you.
We need a love like yours.
It's in your name that we pray. Amen.
Thank you guys for worshiping together
with us. If you want to turn to the
person on your right and left and say,
"The peace of Christ be with you." Then
you may be seated.
on. Sorry, I think I clicked it must
have been on earlier then I clicked it
off to come up here. Perfect. So, um
well uh welcome welcome welcome all of
you. So glad to be with you all. My name
is Brett and the pastor here. pronouns
he him and yeah a joy joy to be with you
to welcome you into the space and that
as always includes those join us online
y'all are not forgotten and uh
especially anyone here tonight who is
new um really glad that you're here I
know lots of different stories come
through those doors and uh you know
often folks can carry a lot of uh
baggage even I mean really just
borderline church trauma from past
experiences you know um and so we are
just grateful that you like had the
courage to come in here into, you know,
a new space, new people, and um we hope
you can feel at ease and uh and just
know that you are wanted and welcome
here. And we hope you can sense that. Um
so, we are in we're kind of wrapping up
a series we've been we've been walking
through the book of First John and uh
the series is No Fear and Love, a study
of First John. And um so the uh the
title of my message tonight as we kind
of wrap up the series is the journey.
And our scripture is 1 John chapter 4 uh
verses 16-18. And it says this. And so
we know and rely on the love God has for
us. God is love. Boy, if you've been
around the table a while and you know my
theology and a lot of the table's
theology, kind of where we're coming
from, it could be captured right there.
That that could be a lot of like just we
really see this as like the very
heartbeat of scripture and and even
though it's not the exact words of
Christ, I mean, I think it's a
reflection of like Christ in essence,
right? This is how do we know that God
is love? Uh well, if you've been with us
for the series or if you're familiar
with the book of First John, John says
because of Jesus. This is how we know.
This is how I can say so confidently God
is love. And in fact, whoever lives in
love
lives in God. That's kind of
interesting. That could be like a whole
different direction for the sermon. You
know, we often wonder how can I connect
with God? How why don't I don't feel God
like other people? You know, how how do
I do this? And it's like, man, if you
are living in love as best you can, like
that's you're in it. You're you're
swimming in God whether you realize it
or not. Whoever lives in love lives in
God and God in them. And this is how
love is made complete among us so that
we will have confidence on the day of
judgment. In this world, we are like
Jesus. Boy, I wish the church could live
into that more. You know, that's that's
how we can have common in this in this
world. We're like Jesus. We carry his
heart, his kind of love. You know there
is no fear
in love. A perfect love drives out fear
because fear has to do with punishment.
Uh but the one who fears is not made
perfect in love. It'll be those last
lines. That's really where we're going
today um in in the message focusing
there. I I think if I could kind of
maybe sum it up, we might say that um
kind of this um almost like a wondering.
And I wonder if in a lot of ways our
whole life is this journey from fear
into love
because of course it does feel
maybe I'm just projecting out onto
others that I it does feel like most of
us kind of um start in this place of
fear. You know, like you you might say
in a lot of ways it's like the kind of
fear almost drives the world forward,
you know, like makes human society go
round, so to speak. Uh I think it was
the uh financial kind of adviser guru
guy Jim Collins. He said, you know, want
you want to know what the stock market
is? Like yes, I mean it's a market
trying to judge, you know, value
companies accurately, whatever, but he
said, you want to know at its like
energetic emotional core, it's two
things. It's greed and it's fear. That's
the like the energy of the And this is
why, you know, it goes up up up and it's
kind of the bull market and everyone's
like piling on like bye bye bye. It's
kind of the greed thing, you know, like
I don't want to get I don't want TO GET
LEFT OUT. I DON'T WANT TO GET LEFT out
of the you know and it's kind of greedy
greed and then what happens and then
it's fear cell sell abandon ship abandon
ship you know it's just greed and fear
greed and fear
but you know I mean it's true fear it
can be productive though you know in
fact I mean it can in a lot of ways
especially like in our kind of society
can like drive you to the heights of
success you know the uh January
was um playoff football time. I know it
kind of culminated the Super Bowl. Some
of you watched it last week, some of you
didn't care. Some of you just love that
halftime show. It was freaking awesome.
Um but uh for all the die hards, you
January was like where like all the
games were happening, whatever. It's
both college and professional. And uh
you know, if you care to you can kind of
observe like the players and coaches
like these folks are like I mean they're
just at the absolute highest level of
their you know games. And um it's
interesting. They all seem like in a lot
of ways so similar to me in the sense of
um I mean there's like a few maybe
players who are just so naturally gifted
that they're like at the upper echelons
but they're like chill, you know, just a
few. And there's maybe a few coaches who
are just so intelligent that they're
like at the very top and they're chill.
But boy, it's just a few. I mean, most
of those like athletes, coaches, they're
just competitive
maniacs, you know? I mean, IT'S JUST
LIKE 100 HOUR WORKS, you know? It's just
like just going banan. And that's kind
of, you know, what it takes. I mean,
especially the something about the
defensive coordinators, you watch
football, these guys just pacing up and
down. I mean, they're just their veins
are bursting. the coaches I'm think
they're just like you know it's just
such an energy like radiating from it's
like dear lord like maniacs you know why
because they must win why must they win
you know I wonder I wonder if it's as
much as it is a kind of desire to win
you know I wonder how much of it is like
the other side of that coin is what a
fear of losing
that Like I wonder for how many of them
that's like maybe there's yes a desire
to win but also like oh we can't you
know what I mean the fear of losing. In
fact I heard an interview with the uh
however many number of Super Bowls six
or seven Super Bowls Tom Brady and he
said in the beginning of his career he
was very driven by the desire to win. He
wanted to get the Super Bowl and have
that you know he said by the end like
the whole second half of his career he
said he would get to the Super Bowl and
when they won he said you know my
dominant emotion was relief. That's what
he said. Relief. He's just like, "Oh,
oh, thank God. Thank God we didn't
lose." Like, that was literally his
emotion was just pure relief. The pain
of losing, the pain of embarrassment, of
falling short of people's expectations.
What is it? Fear.
Fear.
But it's not just markets and sports. I
mean, it's politics, too. You know,
obviously y'all yall tracking the news.
You know, everyone's angry. You know, we
feel the sense of outrage. What's going
on? What's underneath that? You know, I
think there's a fear. It's a lot of
fear. You know, I heard someone say,
"Anger is one of the great disguises of
fear." It's like, it's amazing. Um, it's
amazing, too, though, how your
perspective of others might shift a
little bit if you understood that it's
fear that's driving them. You know what
I mean? Like there's a lot of talk right
now of like a politics of hatred. You
know, they have a politics of hatred.
That tribe has like a politics of
hatred. And yeah, it's how it's
manifesting outwardly. Like, so it's
easy to say, "Ah, it's just cuz they're
just hateful, you know, hateful people,
terrible people." You know, well, what's
underneath that? What's underneath it?
Fear, fear, fear. In fact, I wonder like
if there's um maybe family or folks you
just feel so politically, you know, just
alienated from, you know, I wonder what
it would be like to sit down with them
and not in a kind of like gotcha or like
mean way, but in a kind of genuine way
like cur with true curiosity, ask like
what are you afraid of?
what's what are some of the kind of
social fears? What's what's driving
this? What's under underneath it? You
know, but it's not just markets and
sports and politics, you know. I mean,
it's even like relationships. Think
marriage and parenting and friendships,
you know, what's what's going on in all
these relational dynamics happening. You
know what I mean? If you again scratch
the surface of it, a lot of times it's
so much anxiety and fear, you know what
I mean? Like, oh my gosh, my kid or
how's it going to go? And you know what
I and just start saying crazy things,
doing crazy things, things you would
never like in your right mind just say
or do, but all of a sudden, you know, um
I mean I think even of like our
perfectionism, you know, what's
underneath that, you know, it's like
this fear of like failure or kind of our
need to control control, you know,
what's that fear of like uncertainty?
Just can't be okay with just kind of
like I don't know. I don't know what's
going to happen. It's all right, you
know. No, can't handle that, you know,
fear. What about our FOMO? It's kind of
in the name, you know, but that that
that fear of kind of missing out, fear
of um of kind of being excluded, left
behind, you know. What about like our
jealousy and envy? Fear of not being
good enough. What about arrogance? I
mean, surely like the person who's
arrogant, you know, like they're not
afraid. The opposite. They have too
much, they have so much confidence, it's
gross, you know? Uh what's what's behind
that?
You see, true confidence is quiet and
self- aacing. Arrogance is always loud.
Why? Because it's insecure.
It's it's a fear of not measuring up.
So, it overcompensates,
you know. But it's not just markets and
sports and politics and personal
relationships. Oh, it's religion, too.
More to the point of John, sadly,
perhaps above all, oh, religion.
sweet Christianity
so prone throughout his history to just
I mean more than dabble my notes say
dabble but now that I think about it not
just dabble in fear just like deal in
fear just like way like backstroke in
fear and just living in this this fear
and you can see this playing out in the
Bible we've spoken of this you know many
times before but the Bible is this kind
of chronicle of humanity's evolving
relationship with God you know sometimes
beautiful sometimes
messy, always complicated. I had to be
clear when I say evolving there, I don't
mean God's evolving. I mean we are. It's
our view. Our I think God's the same.
Well, as John says, God is love, right?
He didn't say like God has become loving
through time as he learn you. No, no,
no. God is, always has been, always will
be. God is love. It's us who are
struggling to see this, you know,
rightly. And you see that kind of
chronicle of how this, you know, plays
out. And by this, to be clear, I don't
mean something as clunky as like, you
know, Old Testament bad, New Testament
good, or no, no, there's like beautiful
images of God in the Old Testament and
some kind of weird ones in the New at
times. Um, but mostly if you do read it
though front to back, you again kind of
see a trajectory. You can see people
coming to this conclusion. But it took a
few thousand years to be able to say,
"Okay, no, we're confident God is love."
Because of Jesus Christ, we we're now we
know 100% God is love,
right? As we saw in week one, God is
light. Chapter one says in First John,
"And in him there is no darkness at
all."
All right? And this is what leads to
John's statement in verse 18 that in
fact there is no fear in love. But
perfect love drives out fear. For the
one who fears is not yet made perfect in
love. That's a kind of interesting angle
on it, isn't it? Like this relationship
of like fear and love,
right? Because it's kind of easy to say
like, well, you know, well, I'm a
Christian or I'm a good person, so you
know, of course, like, of course, I'm
loving, you know, but what John seems to
be kind of hinting at is this like a
little bit of a brutal truth, you know,
like to say in essence almost like
you're you're only as loving as you are
free from fear.
Right? In essence, I'm I'm only sort of
like Christ even to the degree that I'm
I'm let letting this great fear start to
fall away from me. Now, I do hate to say
it, but oh, there's so much socalled
biblical theology
that is not yet Christian theology, not
yet Christlike theology because it has
not yet gained John's insight. It's
still shot through with fear
rather than love. Isn't that amazing? I
mean, Christ walked this earth 2,000
years ago. John wrote this letter 2,000
years ago, but it's like we're still
trying to take this in. still trying to
wrap our heads around it to to kind of
uh digest it maybe to switch the
metaphors, you know, to let it kind of
seep into our bones.
Why? How could this be? You know, is
there like is there some conspiracy of
foot like are the uh are the clergy are
they just preaching that fear, you know,
that hell, fire, and brimstone and
you're going to burn, you know, is they
just doing that? But is it like is it
like all a ploy, you know, where they
just know like, man, this manipulates
people and it gets them it gets their
butts in the seats and it gets dollars
and it builds great things and so we're
just going to do, you know, like I'm
just I don't really believe it, but I'm
just going to do it to get, you know,
like, is it just is it just that? Here's
the thing. I've known a lot of pastors,
maybe there's some that are doing that.
Mostly they believe it down to their
toes.
And in essence, they they personally,
it's not just some cynical ploy. They
haven't yet gained John's insight, you
know, to like let it seep into their
bones, right? They too live in this
great fear
and then transmit it.
In fact, before we uh be before we
started the table, our um kind of then
leadership team, what would go on to
become the the first kind of leadership
team of the table and some of the
founding members, um we were meeting
with our former church and some of their
leaders. We're trying to work through
some of our theology and um trying to
find a way to in essence kind of stay
together, you know, um because we were
we were wrestling with specifically
LGBTQ inclusion and we wanted to kind of
move that direction. They were like,
"No, no, you know, and so we we met for
months trying to kind of, you know, work
this um through."
And uh boy, I think everyone had good
hearts. We were trying our best, but it
was just becoming clear the further we
journey like this is not working. Like
this isn't no one's changing anyone's
mind here, you know what I mean? And it
started becoming clear like uh we're
probably going to end up having to um
launch some sort of new community. and
we started to just gently talk about
that, you know, and I think when they
could kind of see that writing on the
wall, we had one um one of our last kind
of official meetings with them and uh
they kind of opened it by saying I mean
basically admonishing us not to do this,
you know, and and they said um we are so
afraid for you.
We're so afraid for you
because if you step out from under this
spiritual covering, we can't guarantee
that you'll be safe.
We're so afraid for you.
Now, you could kind of hear in this
again a kind of cynical ploy, you know,
ah,
they're being manipulative. classic, you
know, classic kind of spiritual abuse,
classic toxic uh Christian leadership,
you know, trying to get people to do by
spreading the fear, you know. Here's the
thing. I know these folks,
I don't think they were being
intentionally manipulative. I think they
were being dead honest.
They were. And they continue to be
genuinely afraid for us.
See, they have a theology that still has
this background
less so than their parents and
grandparents. You know what I mean? But
it's still this kind of latent in the
background. Still this fear. Fear of the
demons, fear of the devil, fear of the
ugly side of God.
You know this fear, it goes so deep in
us that we can't see it. We can't even
see it. Rather, it is that through which
we see everything. It colors everything
we perceive. It distorts everything we
touch. And here's the trick. It's not
like someone has a kind of breakthrough
in this area and then suddenly everyone
they speak to is healed of this great
fear. You know, it's not like a parent
kind of has this breakthrough insight
and really not just knows
intellectually, but like knows in their
own bones. God is love. God is for me,
not against me. And everything we were
singing earlier like knows in their
bones. And then their children just
automatically go all believe it. I'll
believe it and receive it and it's just
like generation just gets passed down
perfectly forever. Just eradicated from
fear, you know. Or it's not like a
pastor has this insight and then
automatically just transmits and
everyone gets it just, you know.
Nope. Every generation, every person
really actually has to discover this for
themselves. A fresh and a new.
And what's the discovery? I would say
it's something like this maturity in the
Christian life. It's this journey. It's
this journey away from fear and towards
love. In fact, we might even say
spiritual growth happens not so much by
striving to become more loving, you
know, which is maybe a lot of the way we
frame it, like I've got to get on it. I
really need to work so I got to get so
much better at loving. And so it's a
kind of gritting your teeth, you know,
and forcing myself. I want to be so
nice. You know,
rather spiritual growth happens by this
increasing awareness of where fear is
still running my life.
That's the insights we need. And as
that's John's insight, right? As the
fear falls away,
then I think in essence, you just shine
as who God's always made you to be. You
know, I mean, it's not like you have to
like sort of add the love to you or
something like no no you're being in
essence like who you are. This is you
are already love itself.
And so as this great fear falls away
then ah you shine as this
uh father Richard Roar he used to lead
men on a five-day um kind of a right of
passage retreat and day three he called
it the the day of grief and he said he
would open that kind of time uh by
saying uh a lot of you think your father
was angry and in many cases he probably
was maybe a lot of you think of
yourselves as angry maybe you are but I
want to give you a great mystery you're
more sad sad than you are angry and so
was your father.
He said every time the room would just
turn ashen and silent. It never failed.
And the whole retreat it kind of hinged
like on that moment where for the first
time they recognized like oh my anger is
like sadness.
The connection I see here is, you know,
why couldn't they in essence just feel
what they felt, you know, and and why
can't we, you know, why why don't we
just acknowledge and feel, you know, the
the grief, the the pain, the sadness?
Why not? Again, fear.
Oh, we're afraid not just of like
external circumstances, you know, oh,
what could go wrong? And we're like just
downright afraid of internal feelings
which we just spend our days avoiding.
This fear goes so deep. Ah but see this
is the invitation. This is the
invitation of Christ to us and the
invitation of I think Christian faith at
its best and of spiritual practices.
Right? In essence, they are all an
invitation to become aware of my fear
and soften into love. Like that's that's
kind of what spiritual practice in the
end. That's its point, you know, to
invite us to become aware, grow aware of
our fear and soften into this love.
I'll close with this. You see, the great
insight of Jesus and the Christian faith
in general is that the healthiest
people, they're drawn by love rather
than driven by fear. It's a good
question even for your own life. You
know, am I am I more drawn by love or am
I more like driven by fear? And not just
in my so-called spiritual life, you
know, whatever that means, my religious
life, I mean just in general, am I more
like drawn by love or am I more driven
by fear? Again, the church has not
always done the best at remembering
this, but it's the truth nonetheless.
The way the a seminary professor of
mine, Dr. Daniel Bruner, put it, he said
this, "The answer to our brokenness is
not holiness,
but rather hearing that we are the
beloved."
I think this is what we as the church
must discover a fresh and a new. God is
love. God is light. And we are made in
God's image which means down deep we too
are pure love and light. Your true
nature is not not only just good. It is
love. Pure love. Your true nature. It is
light. Pure light.
And there's nothing you can do to ever
change that.
There's nothing you can do that can ever
change God's disposition towards you.
God loves you with an everlasting love.
And so you don't have to carry the
weight of the world upon your shoulders.
You can relax. You can stop performing.
God has you and all things.
Soften into that love.
That's the journey.
So, if you're ever here, you know, week
after week and you kind of just wonder
to yourself like,
what are we doing? Like, what
why am I here like Sunday after Sunday?
I think you're here to keep this truth
right in front of you.
This is the journey. It is from fear
into love.
In the name of the father, the son, and
the holy spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread. He broke it. And he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And then he held up a cup of
wine. He said, "Take this drink. This is
my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me.
And so as we come forward, that's the
the process. That's the invitation from
Christ to us. We get to commune with
this great love. Uh the way we'll go
about this tonight is we'll just go
rowby row, starting here at the front
and forming one line in the middle. And
so when one row is done, the next one
can uh jump in line. We practice what's
called an open table. So, if you're here
tonight, you want to participate, then
you are you're free to do that
regardless of your, you know, exact like
theology or denomination or whatever. If
something in you wants to connect with
the risen Christ, then you're you're
welcome to participate. Just know the
red is wine, the white is grape juice.
And finally, you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like. Some
folks take it immediately. Some like to
come and kneel here at the front. Some
return to their seats to partake. Uh but
you can just do that as you as you feel
led. So this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more. So come
come you who have much faith and you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long. You
who have tried to follow and you who
feel like you failed. Come. Come because
it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites
you. And it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here.
Come to the table.
If you guys would like to stand with us
as we close out tonight, we're going to
go back to that first song and just sing
the words that um we can stand in the
love of Christ rather than in the fear
of man
when I stand in your love
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love of my fear doesn't stand a
chance when I stand in your love.
>> Sing that one more time.
>> My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. My fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
love. My fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand in your love.
There's power that can break off every
chain.
There's power that can empty out and gra
power that can save. There's power in
your name. There's power in your name.
The
>> power that can break off every chain.
There's power that can empty out and
graction
power that can save. There's power in
your name. Power in your name.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
step in your love. My fear doesn't stand
a chance when I step in your love. My
fear doesn't stand a chance when I stand
in your love.
>> Thank you so much for joining us this
evening.
If you are new or visiting, we would
love for you to fill out a card at the
table on your way out or you can scan
the QR code and just a little bit of
information and you can also find out
some information on the website about
us. Um,
generosity is a key aspect of life and
adoration in the church. If you would
like to give financially and you are you
call the table home, you can also scan
the QR code and do that or you can visit
the table at the tabletx.org.
Also, if you call the table home and you
do not currently have a meetup,
we have many meetups that meet in
different areas uh in different times of
the week. Um, you may go to the website,
scan the QR code, and maybe find one
that works for you during the time of
the week, um, or the day. Some of them
are once a month. So, we would love to
have you and it's so important to our
community to reach out. Um, my wife and
I have joined meetups and we are so
blessed with our meetup. So just um
think about it and and go to the website
and look look at it.
Okay. I'd like to send you out with the
benediction. You may hold your hand out
in a posture to receive
or you just may open your heart to these
words.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in between,
go
filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
that you are worthy,
and the that you are accepted
just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with.
Be blessed. Have a great week. And we'll
see you again next Sunday. Good night.
>> Stand a chance when I stand your love.
My fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your love. My fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
>> One more. One more. Oh. Oh, my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love. My fear doesn't stand a
chance when I step in your love. My fear
doesn't stand a chance when I step in
your love.
Wow.